Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg testimony
today could lead to new calls for
oversight from Congress the company
faces outrage over the exposure of
personal information from most of its
more than 2 billion users to third
parties a new poll by CBS News and
YouGov shows 61% of Americans say
Congress should do more to regulate
social media and tech companies a
growing number of tech executives seem
to agree Tony - copal spoke to some of
those leaders he's outside Facebook
headquarters which is located at one
hacker Way in Menlo Park California Tony
good morning good morning for most of
its history Facebook's motto was move
fast and break things and that same
spirit has come to define Silicon Valley
producing some of the richest companies
in the world but those on bridled days
may be over and not only for Facebook so
people out here are gonna be watching
Mark Zuckerberg testimony closely 100
percent actually I mean this is the
hottest topic right now
is a typical Silicon Valley success
story I'll show you the app we work on
with homely 30-something CEO running yml
one of America's top app developers but
if you think he's here to tell lawmakers
to back off talk of regulating Facebook
think again you think most tech CEOs in
your position believe Facebook should be
regulated more regulation is necessary
for Silicon Valley I believe so tosh no
wall is echoing the sentiment heard more
and more from CEOs at major tech
companies like uber and Salesforce
rising earnings over the past decade
have made Amazon Apple Facebook and
Google's parent company alphabet among
the most valuable and powerful companies
in the world u.s. tech companies have
largely avoided government oversight and
instead attempted to police themselves
why did we have to wait for a bad thing
to happen before regulators woke up to
the potential for harm here and and
that's a really good question Tony
Facebook was made aware of this in
2015/16 and they pretty much
never made it public so do you think
we'll look back on these days as kind of
the end of the Wild West and earlier I
mean really yeah I think that it has the
makings of that for sure Aaron Levie is
founder and CEO of box a data management
company he started while still in
college
he thinks Facebook's data controversy
could change Silicon Valley forever and
he supports oversight of the tech
industry there are so many examples
where we don't have modern ways of
either regulating controlling or putting
the right protections in place in the
Internet age and this is a fundamental
issue that we're gonna have to grapple
with as an industry for the next decade
he'll be rooting for regulations that
strike a balance between consumer
protection and the need for innovation
if you were to over regulate the
industry and potentially make it really
really difficult to start new companies
or be able to try out new ideas you
might prevent the next Facebook or the
next Google or the next lift from from
ever getting started in the first place
in his prepared testimony Zuckerberg
said protecting the Facebook community
is more important than maximizing profit
yes do you believe him I believe him
because over the long run if you don't
protect the community there will be no
profit to have if Washington decides to
regulate Facebook and Silicon Valley do
you think this age of innovation will be
over
well if Washington decides to regulate
Facebook I think that would be a good
thing and I feel it will be good for
Facebook as well like a lot of people
who do not have the trust in Facebook
will probably have more trust if
Facebook is regulated
now Zuckerberg prepared testimony for
Congress does not mention the word
regulation but in an interview last
month he said he's open to it if it's
quote the right regulation Nora all
right Tony thank you so much